welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and light year is pixar's toy story
spin-off with chris evans voicing the
version of buzz lightyear from the
blockbuster sci-fi movie that andy's toy
and video game were based on and that
film is a martian style nasa punk jam
that rocks out with its socks out to
bowie with photorealistic animation
blurring us deep into the uncanny valley
of buzz's crystal blue eyes hoping we
get lost to infinity and who knows
because chris evans is never allowed to
complete a catchphrase to infinity
and
[Music]
avengers
pop what
what is he trying to say pop what
magnitude i am gonna break down this
trailer frame by frame for this movie's
plot how it connects to the toy story
films and maybe some other pixar movies
and all the easter eggs and animation
details that you might have missed in
this trailer here we go
okay the trailer opens on a star command
base that looks like it's on a dusty
planet surface with craters in the
foreground we know this planet has an
earth-like atmosphere because characters
can breathe the air now this movie's
director angus mclean asked what was the
movie that andy saw when we made toy
story why don't we just make that movie
so this movie is the blockbuster film
that the buzz lightyear toys and video
games and other products would be based
upon and it's an epic in the vein of
star wars which toy story 2 definitely
referenced with zerg being buzz
lightyear's father you killed
[Music]
but here a close-up shows buzz's dog tag
listing a scannable barcode and his
blood type as o positive making him a
universal donor and in the hangar bay
are a bunch of robots lifters kind of in
the style of the robots of wall-e
actually i'm wondering if this could be
part of operation recolonize which was
the reason the axiom and the other ships
evacuated humanity from earth in the
wally film because at b l space is the
final fun tier
and we later found out that that
operation was abandoned operation
cleanup has
well uh failed
what you know rising toxicity levels
have made life
unsustainable on earth darn it all we're
going to have to cancel operation
recolonize so space command's mission
here could be to find other sustainable
worlds for humanity to recolonize now
buzz's ship is fueled with a crystal a
callback to the crystalline fusion he
mentioned back in the first toy story
film i need to repair my turbo boosters
do people still use fossil fuels or have
you discovered crystallic fusion well
let's see we got double a's moving on
with the rest of the trailer
[Applause]
okay here you'll notice buzz's flight
path is projected via this light source
into his cockpit and it looks like his
origin planet is not earth which doesn't
have any landmasses or craters that look
like that from what i know it seems like
the path is slingshotting him around the
sun to gain speed via gravitational
forces and then cross him through these
three rings now actually there's a later
shot of a whiteboard that confirms that
buzz hits hyperspeed right between the
sun and these rings that causes him to
experience time dilation and progress
one year into the future for every
minute of time from his perspective this
is in accordance with einstein's theory
of relativity we saw this similar
concept play out an interstellar in
which gravitational variances causes
time to dilate on a planet at a ratio of
for every hour from their perspective
seven years past on the ship so this is
going to make buzz lightyear a man out
of his time which is fitting for the guy
who played a time dilated hero captain
america steve rogers in the marvel films
that could actually be why his companion
whose name badge labels her hawthorne
goes from having longer hair and
whiteboard shot to shorter braided hair
in the other shots and since this flight
path returns to his origin buzz could
just be a test pilot who returns to this
planet planet of the ape style to find
everything much older and you'll notice
the preflight announcer says flight
recorders are on suggesting that this
mission control will have a record of
how time will pass from buzz's
perspective inside the cockpit recalling
that recording in the pod and one of my
favorite movies contact that i bring up
all the time which in that movie later
proved to be a major piece of evidence
that gets buried showing jodie foster's
character did make her time dilated
journey with the flight recording 18
hours of static despite from earth's
perspective it occurring instantaneously
hawthorne watches on for mission control
and notice she has a scar through her
eyebrow that could be something that she
received during that time dilated period
between buzz's departure and his return
next clip
okay buzz's hyper launch streaks the
stars toward him evoking the classic
hyperspace jump from the star wars
movies and his helmet reads zero one
which could be for him being the first
test pilot to go on this kind of mission
he's their number one guy in buzz's
close-up i like how his eye color is a
more natural shade of blue than the blue
paint used for his toy equivalent these
pixar animators are the best especially
with the way light hits surfaces and
produces different shades in this case
paint on plastic would reflect light
differently than his more natural
organic eyes would buzz puts up some
hexagonal shielding on his cockpit to
protect it from the solar radiation as
he rounds the sun and we move on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we now find buzz inside his living
quarters maybe reflecting on how his
world has changed during his time
dilation and then this adorable robotic
cat walks up to him its tag later on
lists its name as sucks s-o-x and his
shirt reads property of star command
with the numerical code beneath just a
bit of a joke with buzz considering
himself a government instrument with a
serial number the way toys have serial
numbers but also the way buzz feels like
he is being used like a piece of
property but this video is brought to
you by the ridge the ridge wallet is
light sleek and industrial it's designed
to fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky monstrosities that make a sit
crooked when they're in our back pockets
the ridge comes in over 30 styles and
colors including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash so you can show
off your fancy euro collection to
cashiers and other people who probably
don't care every ridge wallet comes with
a lifetime guarantee and they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it they also have great backpacks phone
cases and other cool gear so get 10 off
today with free worldwide shipping and
returns by going to ridge.com new
rockstars that's ridge.com new rockstars
and use code new rockstars find the link
in the video's description now
throughout the trailer is david bowie's
starman a song used also in the martian
soundtrack bowie's lyrics describe a
lonely space traveler his ziggy stardust
persona coming to a new planet to mount
a cultural revolution which does echo
the isolation of this star man buzz
lightyear but my favorite thing about
the song is bowie's composition of the
chorus that octave leap on star
man that was actually meant to
melodically echo somewhere
over the rainbow and even bowie
sometimes during his concerts would
alter the words to there's a star man
over the rainbow and he did that to link
the journeys of ziggy stardust with
dorothy gail and now we are linking it
to buzz lightyear as a lonely traveler
to a strange unfamiliar world buzz and
another robot pick up at his ship in a
swamp planet that reminds me a lot of
dagobah with luke and r2 and empire
strikes back this is likely the planet
that we see buzz falling with style upon
in the later shot and in the mist there
is this menacing robot with a red eye
actually later on in the trailer we see
rows of these robots each marked with a
z these are the zerg bots you remember
these rex bought these while playing as
buzz in the video game at the start of
toy story 2 which means zerg is coming
folks now buzz walks out on the base
showing a massive structure being
constructed with cranes in the
background giving you a sense of the
scale this structure kind of matches the
shape of space mountain at the disney
parks as one of the few attractions left
not yet claimed by a film ip i give it
about two years before it's remade into
the star command or something like that
then there's a shot of buzz's commanding
officer named patch reading burnside and
judging from his many triangular patches
compared to the seated junior officer
he's likely a top ranking officer like
an admiral who might be sending buzz on
this mission and might be the guy who
considers him expendable which is why
he's like commandeering the controls
right here on to the next clip
[Music]
okay we see the moment buzz first meet
sucks the robocat which freaks them out
into this karate pose reminding us of
the buzz lightyear toys karate chop
function the robot also comes with a
mouse toy of course and then when he
drops socks this robot as all cats do
lands on its feet then we see buzz
getting attacked by a green tentacle
that hawthorne slashes with a laser
blade and then socks the robocat plugs
his tail into an outlet in the ship as
it scans a computer similar to the way
r2d2 uses a skomplink in star wars then
security bursts into buzz's room 27a
armed with laser guns that have the
fixated unfiring pointer similar to the
laser that buzz has on his toy arm i'm
guessing from this buzz we'll run afoul
of star commands true mission and have
to go rogue at some point but then we
move on to the final clip
to infinity
and
[Music]
okay after this shot of the lined up
zerg bots this chamber opens up with
smoke and red lighting from inside i'm
assuming this will be the reveal of
emperor zerg though i'm surprised if
this movie will make zerg buzz's father
that was kind of a goopy thing from the
games and the toys this movie seems a
bit more grounded and then we get the
classic buzz lightyear space ranger suit
hanging in the locker room it looks
surprisingly practical we get great
looks at it here and as buzz wears it
and it retains its blue red and green
buttons that light-year sticker the sr
space ranger sticker on the arm and then
the star command wings emblem in the
center of the chest plate and i love how
the light reflects more cleanly off the
emblem than it does off the rest of the
matted green paint on the chest plate
it's just a cool subtle way of showing
how this armor is really made up of
different components as opposed to it
all being plastic with the toy now
hawthorne has her own space ranger suit
she's also a space ranger but now hers
is mark zero one suggesting she might
have moved up to replace buzz during his
time gone and that piece is right where
the laser sticker and button normally
are on the toy suggesting these space
rangers might not yet be equipped with
lasers which should make them easier to
kill off when they become expendable i'm
loving the look of this film as always
pixar animation is just cutting edge
photo realistic but still maintaining a
bit of the animated cartoony style so we
don't get trapped in the uncanny valley
and i just love conceptually how they're
expanding this world i'm super excited
for this film and if you're super
excited about what we do here at new
rockstars you can support us by checking
out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching and to infinity and
don't call me on don't come off
[Music]
you